bon soit costantini géopolitologue
bonjour françois constantini merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france ce matin
on vient de le voir les célébrations du
9 mai on réussisse son plus important en
tant que celle du 8 mai en france
comment on peut expliquer un tel
décalage bonjour merci de votre mutation
qui m'honore tout particulièrement
je pense qu'il ya un contraste en effet
entre cette parade magnifique ce round
commémoration qui est exceptionnel au
monde
et puis les cérémonies rabri riquiqui je
pense qu'ils ne font pas vraiment
honneur en france à aux sacrifices qui
se sont dévoués
il y à il ya soixante il ya 76 ans
première chose moi je pense que je me
souviens un peu ans bien 74 j'étais
encore écoliers et ma famille avait été
choqué parce que valéry giscard
d'estaing nouvellement élu avait déclaré
qu on ne célébrait luminet le lit mais
je cite où c'est le bras et de façon au
moindre set c'était plus le férié mais
pour me disent et ils pourront pas d t
on pas d'écart à l'allemagne avec la can
count somme-là engageant la construction
européenne tout est dit je pense
qu'aujourd'hui pour pas déplaire à
l'allemagne on n'en fait pas trop pour
l'onu mais alors que c'est une grande
victoire
on sait s'ils vont pouvoir des alliés
c'est une victoire bien sûr des peuples
de l'union soviétique du peuple russe
semble en particulier et je pense que
comme la dimension au roi tout à l'heure
ça aurait dû être au moment où mahmoud
communion internationale entre tous les
anciens les anciens alliés les peuples
ont ce petit peuple russe français
britannique américain mais je pense que
aujourd'hui on est plus soucieux en
effet d'écarter la russie de ces
cérémonies est de faire que dire en
quelque sorte de ne pas froisser en
quelque sorte
l'allemagne et je pense que c'est assez
choquant là françois à constantine et à
en quoi le souvenir 2000
soldats tombés sur le champ de bataille
continue même 76 ans après cimenté
justement la nation russe et à c'est un
sacrifice sans bien sûr retirer le
mérite l'engagement des battants alliés
américains britanniques australiens de
la résistance française faut pas oublier
il faut quand même pas oublier que sur
les 5 millions et demi de soldats au que
l'allemagne nazie a perdu elle en a a
laissé 4 millions sur le champ de
bataille soviétiques et que le l'époque
de l'union soviétique le peuple russe
particulièrement ou ont dû à déplorer 20
millions de morts donc je pense que la
victoire et c'est à l'ancien c'est un
anti communiste anti soviétique qui nous
parle
la victoire en effet contre l'allemagne
nazie c'est l'union soviétique ce sont
les pubs d'union soviétique qui ont eu
le plus grand le plus grand sacrifice
ils ont commis qui se sont le plus
engagées
je crois que la victoire possible a été
rendue possible parce que par le rouleau
compresseur de l'armée rouge et ça il
faut pas l'oublier et je pense que je
suis heureux de voir ne prend tout cas
le le peuple russe garder en tout cas
une certaine fierté
on voudrait que de l'autre côté de
l'europe ce soit un petit peu pareil
depuis longtemps et garder ce ciment en
quelque sorte de l'histoire et et
montrer que la nation russe et est fier
d'elle et quelque part ça rassure en
quelque sorte de moi toujours une russie
qui porteront ses couleurs pendant son
discours
vladimir poutine a réaffirmé je cite que
le pays défendra ses intérêts est ce que
vous savez à quoi il fait allusion
je pense que l'otan depuis il va dire
poutine accéder la présence de la russie
la russe qui est revenue je crois que en
toute simplicité dans le jeu
international
c'est à dire qu'on a vu la déliquescence
où j'ai assisté il mettait en russie fin
91 gp d'ailleurs si je parle un peu
personnel au moment des 50 ans de la
défense de moscou 87 des gens sentent
révérence et cette ferveur
je pense que la russie tout simplement
et robin d'anjou internationale elle
fait valoir ses intérêts sans
agressivité mais elle également s est
relevé et je pense que en effet
aujourd'hui il ya une politique qui à
mon sens dangereuses à l'égard de la
russie
ces 700 tentatives
extension de l'otan à l'est au leader de
la russie qui ne peut que accentuer la
fracture intra européennes et là je te
comprend en effet que la russie pose un
certain nombre d'intérêts quant à sa
sécurité quant à un défi alors
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons des menaces
comme l'islamisme radical mondial comme
le terrorisme comme les défis
migratoires
est ce qu'on a besoin d'introduire une
fracture majeure au sein de l'europe et
d'avoir cette guerre froide larvé avec
la russie moi je réponds non
et je comprends les faits que la russie
défendre ses intérêts et je pense qu'il
faut converger justement faire de la
russie à l'interlocuteur et non pas un
adversaire vous parler de fracture
le président vladimir poutine a
également rappelé je cite le retour dans
le monde d'idéologie à raciste et
russophone est ce que c'est quelque
chose que vous ressentez aussi oui parce
qu'on voit un peu partout dans les
discours surtout depuis l'arrivée
d'administration by donne aux états unis
je cite et puis quand on regarde les
rapports il ya un le rapport au temps
2030 dans lesquelles sont désignés comme
comme adversaire un la russie de la
chine les pays de occidentaux les états
unis les pays européens at il pas
d'autres adversaires aujourd'hui je
pense pas que ce soit la russie et la
chine qui en france est et fait plus de
360 morts je veux parler bien sûr des
morts de l'islamisme radical que nous
avons des pleurs en france et il n'y a
pas longtemps également une policière à
son cou succombé sous l'ailé sous les
coups d'un fanatiques islamistes et je
pense qu'en effet il s'agit d'une fausse
route qui risquent en effet de conduire
vers la bim verna un affrontement
totalement décalée avec les enjeux et je
pense qu'il faut cesser en effet deux
des conseils de considérer la que les
états unis considère la russie comme
le common adversaire privilégié à la
demie stratégie comme avait dit georges
bush et qu'il faut revenir à la raison
au plan international